هذه الصور ايضا للرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب يتحدث مع انصاره هناك تجمع متواجد
ايضا في ميامي والرئيس ترامب يتحدث مع
الناس ومع انصاره في هذه الصور التي تصلنا
تباعا نذهب الى لنستمع الى صوت الطبيعي
ومن ثم نعود
الرئيس
لوقوفك في وجههم في وجه هؤلاء الشيوعيين
الذين منحوا كوبا الى الصين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
ما زلنا نتابع الرئيس ترامب مع بعض انصاره
في ميامي يلقي التحيه عليهم ويتحدثون معه
وطبعا يساندونه في هذه اللحظات الصعبه
التي يمر بها الرئيس ترامب من خلال هذه
المحكمه التي مثل امامها لمده تقريبا ربع
ساعه نصف ساعه وقال بانه غير مذنب وطبعا
اليوم الاجراءات الامنيه كانت مشدده جدا
في ميامي نستمع اذا كان يتحدث الرئيس
ترامب الان
يشكرون يشكرهم وايضا هم يعبرون عن حبهم
للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
وايضا ياخذون صور تذكاريه مع الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب
وطبعا ما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور
المباشره مما ياميل الرئيس ترامب مع بعض
من انصاره ومحبيه اشكرك حتى الان زميلنا
حسين الطاوود اعطيتنا صوره واضحه عن
الاجواء التي كانت بمحيط هذه المحكمه التي
غادرها ترامب منذ قليل ووصل الى هذا
التجمع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعني لا ادري هذا اليوم كان عيد ميلاده
الحقيقي ولكن نتابع
المناصرين الذين ينشدون اغنيه او يتمنون
له ايضا عيد ميلاد سعيد وهو الان ياخذ صور
تذكاريه مع محبيه وانصاره
لدينا بلدا بات فاسدا بلدا يعاني من شح
المياه ولا يوجد فيه الا المشاكل الكثيره
وترون وضع الناس اين باتت احوالهم واين
تجهت لدينا
الان في حاله
شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]
يشكر الرئيس ترامب مناصريه وكانت تحدث
بانه
سيلتقي ايضا بمناصريه وسيكون له ايضا خطاب
معهم الليله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات